hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play to never sing that spider fu
I'm getting the Frick and frack out of
here because obviously there's nothing
else I need and you guys have pointed me
towards where the Easter Egg door is so
I will head that way and get out of here
no matter how dark the momma yeah read
that one love and help are always
talking blah blah blah blah blah why do
I still have the monsters near music
okay so now I have the castle key and
[ __ ] war but fail all right what fail
there we go dink
the woods are lovely dark and deep but I
have promises to keep and miles to go
before I sleep
that's what you said
hello anybody ah ha this door they said
it was by a save that I hadn't well oh
come on really it's gonna be that you're
gonna make it that easy for me let's
find out life's but a walking shadow a
poor player that struts and frets his
hour upon my bowling galley
you
ah ah
get this what the Big Shot cut was not
not a good shot I fired what are you
trying to accomplish
looking like idiot what's a good job huh
what a strike two might be spot ah come
on oh you can throw manages I believe I
can throw beautiful Jade I think above
all we threw you even better than you
throw it shut up I got a strike
you saw wha what the good shot ah no
more ops you could get a lesson in how
to use balls what are you trying to calm
I'm going looking like you shove this
ball what's the deal before up your ass
well you're gonna be spotted up green be
[ __ ] god I swear I was going to
compliment you look at bowling ball
today huh yeah
ah okay
I think there's a prize for actually
getting soviet/russian
the ball would throw you Brian better
than you throw it what a strike to Matt
be spot
whatever man okay all right hey are you
trying to come
I'm done he long like they did me what
the good job okay then bye bye bye bye
MA
lash put a walking shadow a poor player
that struts and frets his hour upon the
stage and is heard no more okay that was
fun I was ridiculous but it's fun so
anyway now back to the terror that is to
never sleep
oil how did I miss that
mm-hmm the same place
oh is that found huh text the padlock
the padlock is therefore further secure
security
you'll be able to enter right okay
hello spitting baby face now I'm out so
whatever let's go down to the morgue
love the morgue ah
okie dokie
alright I'm okay I'm okay this is fine
both of me not even a little bit the
morgues a long load which means it's a
big level
a whole new chapter a alright I can deal
with that hell's that
ah safe own ass
oh and by these tinderboxes how do you
laughs ooh yeah I'm fat oh boy
so much oil literally this guy's giving
me ridiculous amounts below I swear oh
hello her all these are made it's doing
here what do you think we take the dead
bodies and put them in a call back then
we put them in Geier inmates to train
the what we see here to examine them
after there are easier ways to drain a
person's blood I would know our mains
also would poke many holes in them I may
have said too much about myself oh I
thought I saw something
whatever I don't know
no not today mr. spider
oh okay you want some mr. spider I'll
take you on okay
but ah if you need to talk to the doctor
down here we need to get the combination
to the log to the castle then you would
need to go through the gates up ahead
and into his room into his room ah damn
you spider yes I understand
what did I get a memento for open the
front gate protecting the inner gate
leading doctor room open the second day
preventing actus okay how many gates are
there three or two whatever okay that's
a gate that's a sewer grate all right
Oh
Babloo
Oh doggy Oh Lord
pull back out wasn't moving fast reading
I was explaining like what it was like I
don't even know what it was just chasing
you very fast by Ralph
you'll look okay oh I see we're gonna
like put coal in here I don't know I
needed that it was plenty light in this
room okay okay Oh
was that it's been one of them new
monsters boy was not expecting it sure
but anyway I'm a rock I will persevere
I've got plenty of these tender bark ah
come on
tell me this was just a dead end any
goodies and goodies not even a goodie
wow what a waste of my life at least
their torches are actually pieces oh
here we go
whoa what duh huh raise that water is
that actually a pin into the abyss I
think it's a pin into the abyss huh huh
huh
your goodies down here goodies it bound
to be goodies right right it's been
goodies everywhere else we'll get back
up cuz I failed
ah no failed is not I'm surprised I
lived from that actually now that I
think about it I don't think I've ever
died from a fall in amnesia in any of
the custom stories I play I think I ever
have uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh I will if I
fall again because I have no help okay
this wrong is wrong so wrong where I
don't even know where I'm headed ah hey
UMP I jump and I jump again oh don't
tell me this is where I started ah
another Fagin
yup yup this seems dangerous it's team
dangerous I don't know what the point is
but I'm doing it just the same sassafras
at least when I when I go up there when
I got the letter I should be close to
where I was headed right so I thought I
don't even know where I'm headed but I
think I'm trying to get to the opposite
end of the room I don't know if you can
die well there's nothing here okay
that's where I came in
nothing over the place there's no
there's nothing over there behind me was
there even a point coming here I don't
know if there was now maybe if I try to
go over to the right there no damn it um
and again I didn't die wow this must
wait oh wait no of course of course it's
through here it's down is where I'm
supposed to be ah let me just take some
laudanum some way vision isn't so red
I'm an idiot officially I am an idiot
dammit
hey buddy
hey pieces of my old buddy hey piggies
hey everybody
Brad no points yeah all right
ah oil hairs I knew there had to be
somewhere around here I mean I've been
wandering around for enough time anyway
okay so that's there it's down there
I'm actually gonna like I've said before
ah come on
I've had before me custom stories that
I'm gonna do I'm actually gonna use my
tinderboxes but in this one I really am
like no joke damn it everything's locked
what's the point of even coming down
here
okay alright that's all the time I got
for this episode thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part bye bye